er ist das problem wladimir putin
russlands präsident russlands kriegsherr
der mann der die ukraine zerbombt der
mann der kriegsverbrechen dieser mann
muss weg das zumindest ist das große
thema eines geheimtreffens nahe der
litauischen hauptstadt vilnius knapp
1000 kilometer vom kreml entfernt
dort treffen sie sich zum weg mit putin
gipfel mitten im litauischen wald der
name des weiträumig abgeriegelten
tagungsortes esperanza hoffnung
mit dabei litauens aussenminister
landsbergis putin experten und putin
kritiker aus der ganzen welt auch bild
ist mit dabei im zentrum die die
politisierung russlands ziel des gipfels
sei eine strategie den bären zu
erschlagen so ein teilnehmer dazu werden
hinter den dicht verschlossenen türen
drei szenarien durchgespielt
szenario 1 das reich putins zerbröckelt
langsam bis es samt putin am boden liegt
szenario 2 putin wird weggeputscht von
armee und geheimdienste
szenario 3 1 auf stand von unten eine
art bürgerkrieg doch egal wie putin muss
weg da sind sich die teilnehmer dieses
geheim gipfels in den litauischen
wäldern einig
freiwillig werde putin niemals abtreten
ein gipfelteilnehmer zu bild putin wird
den kreml mit den füßen zuerst verlassen
rückte war mit vor ort in litauen dort
nahe der hauptstadt vilnius ist jetzt
dort in der hauptstadt zurück julia
nicht grüße dich bei bild am abend
dieser anti putin gipfel lasst uns
einmal noch mal hinter die kulissen
schauen wie realistisch sind diese
szenarien die dadurch gespielt wurden
ja also realistisch sind sie schon da
sind so viele teilnehmer sicherheit
wissen dieser szenarien ebenen
stattfindet also entweder tatsächlich
wie durch ein wunder ein putin der
irgendwann nachgibt und sagt so okay wir
haben jetzt um die demokratische partei
abgewählt wird das glaubt aber
eigentlich keiner das zweite szenario
eben dass die elite sozusagen sagt wir
haben zu viele verluste immer keine
kriegen beispielsweise wir wollen dass
ich mir wir wollen auch wieder handeln
das geht dass die oligarchen sagen wir
wollen zurück auf unsere yachten in der
in der algarve und so weiter und dass
sie liegen dann wegrutschen oder eben
das dritte szenario und davor haben auch
die programm gegner heute gewarnt ist
eben dieser dieser revolution von unten
also das sozusagen der kleine arme
erschütterte man eben in ganz russland
auch begehrt und dann ganz regionale
konflikte rauskommen und eben das
auseinanderbricht viele teilrepubliken
kleine länder so wie es eben 1990
teilweise der fall war das muss ich auch
sagen oder prinzip zumindest sagen die
teilnehmer das wollen auch sie nicht
aber das ist auch ein mögliches szenario
für das ende putins die tatsache dass du
dabei warst du auch hinter den
verschlossenen türen das deute darauf
hin dass eben das kein treffen von
träumern war sondern das waren treffen
von experten und auch
regierungsvertreter waren dabei julian
das ist richtig also das ist ein
treppenwitz in verschiedenen
konstellationen zu seit mehreren jahren
stattfindet ich war mehrmals dabei hat
mir das vertrauen so ein bisschen
erworben und durfte deshalb als einziger
deutscher journalist sozusagen mit rein
nicht erst heute um 13.30 zur
abschlusspressekonferenz sondern eben
schon seit seit gestern nachmittag
sozusagen sei das los gegangen ist und
ja aus sicherheitsgründen kann ich
weiterhin nur sagen der veranstalter war
eben das litauische außenministerium mit
herrn landsbergis der außenminister der
das veranstaltet hat und eben der
berühmteste wenn man so möchte und auch
der einzige russe der in die
öffentlichkeit getreten ist ist michael
rohowski ehemals reichste mann russlands
jetzt seit jahren nach der politischen
haft im ausland im exil bekämpft dort
putin die beiden sind heute von die
presse gegangen die beiden sind
offiziell da die anderen 68 kenne ich
teilweise sie kommen von beiden seiten
des atlantiks sie kommen ja sie kommen
aus aus aus verschiedenen euro ländern
und eben die überwiegende zahl also mehr
als erster teilnehmer sind russen das
ist ganz wichtig eine russische
perspektive und eben einem jahr an ein
russisches szenarien durchgespielt
werden nicht um eine art regime schenks
aus dem ausland das halte ich noch mal
für ganz wichtig